joker et batman version chocolat chaque
créature mesure 1 mètre 20 et pèse 60 kg
une vitrine alléchante devant laquelle
s'arrêtent admiratifs de nombreux
passants bienvenue chez les klein ici on
est chocolatier de père en fils depuis
trois générations
paul est le petit fils c'est lui et ses
élèves qui ont façonné les figurines
exposé un travail minutieux qui
inspirait sa femme clémence pour pâques
elle a repris l'idée du masque du super
héros je suis parti d'un oeuf
vous voyez la femme de l'oeuf et ensuite
donc l'idée c'était de mettre un masque
de batman sur sur l'oeuf et donc pour le
déguiser j'étais sculpté en chocolat
j'ai fait des rajouts avec du chocolat
pour former le masque de batman
ensuite on fait un moule ont fait en
résine et ensuite on fait un moule en
plastique qu'on peut dupliquer à
l'infini à l'infini grâce à cette
machine venue d'angleterre
le couple est le seul à en posséder une
en franche comté
ça permet d'être créatif
et en même temps productif en maître
chocolatier paul reprend la main et
vaporise une fine couche de chocolat
pour donner de l'éclat au masque avant
de le garnir de deux couches plus
épaisse pour lui donner vie
il imagine des yeux plus vrai que nature
chaque couche de chocolat et ajouté en
simultané on va dire j'attends pas que
ça refroidisse
du coup le chocolat tous les chocolats
vont se pousser les uns aux autres et ça
va faire un aspect un peu fondu naturel
comme une vraie juristes en fait
vient ensuite l'étape de l'assemblage à
quatre mains délicatement clémence fixe
les yeux sous le masque pendant que paul
referme les oeufs et cet ensemble dans
un dernier geste que leur nouvelle
création prend vie chaque année on
essaie de faire une nouvelle collection
pour attirer le client
c'est important de se recycler
d'apporter
[Musique]
d'apporter de la nouveauté mais c'est
vrai qu'en ce moment on est très super
héros dans le monde médiatique et le
cinéma c'est quelque chose qu'il voulait
bien aux enfants dans mon petit garçon
en cinq jours paul et clément seront
fabriqués 200 masque de batman
ils viendront compléter les 600 poules
lapins et poissons déjà présents dans le
magasin à coup sûr tous trouveront enfin
pas les prêts à les engloutir